welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and you're now
locked into the channel where we've been
watching The Watchmen to break down
everything that you need to know about
the new season on HBO throughout this
video we were capping the third entry in
the season this fall and discussing
where the show could be heading in the
future there will be heavy spoilers here
so if you haven't had a chance to watch
episode three yet and don't want to know
what happens then I highly suggest that
you turn off now without the way I just
want to give a huge thank you for
clicking this video now let's get into
our breakdown of Watchmen episode three
so far and Watchmen we've unearthed a
huge conspiracy inside the police
department that showed one of its
high-ranking officers was linked with a
white supremacist group known as the
seventh cavalry that carried out attacks
on police and the public episode three
carries on this narrative but it mainly
answers a lot of questions that people
have had about the show and how it ties
in with the original graphic novel this
time we learn a lot of the history of
the universe since the 80s and also
discover what's been going on with some
of the characters of the source material
the episode opens with Laurie Blake
reaching out to dr. Manhattan to tell
him a joke in classic Watchmen style
it's got a really dark punch line to it
and this episode very much centers
around Laurie and her actions now from
the off this is clearly Silk Spectre jr.
and those who are familiar with the
source material will recall that she was
a pivotal part in it and also the
ex-girlfriend of dr. Manhattan since
changing her name at the end of the
graphic novel she was very clearly on
earth and has created a deal with the
government in order to not go to jail
for those who don't know what Laurie was
closely tied to the government through
her relationship with dr. Manhattan and
we can assume that this gave her some
leniency upon being captured
she has slowly risen through the ranks
of the FBI and is now a commanding
officer that takes down vigilantes
Laurie used to be one but she clearly
has seen firsthand that allowing them to
operate could lead to the death of
millions as happened at the end of the
she's had a very bad experience with
vigilantes in the past and even though
she used to rank amongst them her change
of heart makes sense in light of the
actions of Ozymandias her heart clearly
still fawns for both night owl and dr.
Manhattan and in her apartment we see a
pet owl named who as well as a blue
dildo later in the episode
I wonder if chairs duplicate to that
anyway we learn that night owl aka dan
dreiberg has been arrested for being a
vigilante and Senator Joseph Keene whose
father was behind the Keene act that
outlawed mass crime fighters in the
first place
tasks her with investigating captain
Crawford's murder promising her that if
he becomes president he will free her
love Laurie really has a rich past her
mother was the original Silk Spectre her
father was the comedian and she has had
relationships with both night owl and
dr. Manhattan however she is at a point
where she seems like she just wants to
be as far away from the life of a
superhero as possible due to all the
mystery that it caused her this long
shadow is difficult to escape from and
it's clear that many are enamored with
her and her reputation the portrayal is
awesome and quickly Laurie became my
favorite character in the show when
reading the comics I was never that
bothered by her finding a pretty
uninteresting and boring and don't even
get me started on the movie's depiction
because yeah there's a reason Malin
Akerman didn't do much after it however
jeans smart nails this painting out the
character is a hardened cop that only
really lets down her guard when talking
through the phone to her one connection
to a past
dr. Manhattan now I'm gonna get into
what I sort of took this as and I might
be wrong so make sure you leave your
thoughts on my analysis of this so we
know that dr. Manhattan is a god and
that he is above all else the most
powerful being in the universe Laurie is
still very much a follower of him and in
some way she views him as a god as well
they're reaching out to him through the
phone is this universes version of
praying and though she knows she won't
get a response she still tries over and
over because she believes in him and
thinks that one day just one day he may
sort her problems out we learned that
many people try and reach out to him but
he never responds and this is almost
like a church for them it's certainly
done and whilst I may be wrong this
reminded me a lot of confessional booths
and churches and on the whole I found it
a nice metaphor she knows the truth
behind the square
and because of this views herself as a
monster doomed to go to hell which
perhaps is the reason that she
constantly turns to religion again and
had the joke later but that was just my
thought on why she goes to this booth
anyway she arrives at the crime scene
where Judd was found hanged and quickly
notices wills tire tracks in the dirt
this leads her to Looking Glass who she
hilariously tears apart and puts down if
you've been keeping up to date with the
channel you know how much I think that
this guy is gonna be one of the big
villains and she makes a mockery of his
costume even using his mask as a mirror
to pick her teeth
Laurie due to what she's done now what
really doesn't trust anyone and she is
obsessed by her past and how much it
bears weight on the present and future
she like her mother is completely
consumed by it who remembers Silk
Spectre senior saying everyday the
future looks a little darker but the
past even the grimy parts of it well
they just keep getting brighter all the
time Laurie has clearly inherited this
view and she is very cynical throughout
this reintroduction everything in this
episode though builds the herd getting
to meet Angela face to face it's Judds
funeral and yet there are obvious
similarities here between this and the
comedian's both were clearly bad people
even though they were admired by the
public and angela is forced to deliver a
eulogy discussing how much of a good
manager it was even though this wasn't
the case in the backdrop of this is a
member of the seven cavalry who crawls
underground her geodes mausoleum
denouncing senator keen as a race
traitor that has to be brought in Laurie
however snuck a gun in and manages to
shoot him second guessing that the
cavalry member was lying about the bomb
being rigged to his heart rate however
it turns out that he wasn't bluffing and
Angela manages to avert more deaths
though Judds body is destroyed by the
explosion
throughout this scene we once more have
the return of the ticking clock and it
reminds us that the countdown is on
elsewhere in the episode we see Osmund
Isis plan begin to flesh out there are
more squids and a miniature catapult
that will no doubt be used in some way
we can guess that Ozzy is testing a suit
for the temperatures of space and is
even a black freighter Easter Egg thrown
in there that is clearly hinting about
what's going to happen as human Dyess is
building something that he needs to be
thick and durable capable of moving
humans through a range of temperatures
Ozzy is stopped from getting a buffalo
skin by a masked Horseman
let alone that this is the games warden
from this we discovered that Ozzy was
indeed captured and put in exile on the
island clearly they know what as he did
at the end of the graphic novel but if
the truth ever came out it would cause
the world economy to collapse so he has
been placed here due to his wealth he
probably has free reign but they are
aware of his plan and will not let him
proceed with another Adrian rebuffs this
but we know and the games warden knows
that he's up to something
donning his infamous costume for the
episodes big money shot which cements
that he is definitely back now
personally I believe that Ozzy is either
on the moon or on Mars and a prisoner of
dr. Manhattan in Episode one we saw doc
building a castle on Mars and this was
very similar to the one that Adrian now
lives in personally I believe that Ozzy
is looking for a way to build a suit
that can protect the inhabitant through
the coldness of space and he will use
the catapult to shoot himself off of the
planet in order to get back to earth
this makes a lot of sense to me
especially with the procedures that he
is going through and the clones could be
creations of dr. Manhattan Ozzy is
clearly somewhere that he can't escape
from and trying to build a suit in order
to get away what he does when he returns
to Earth we don't know yet but yeah this
is all starting to fall into place back
in Oklahoma there's a mention of an
intrinsic feel generator being built by
Russia which for those who don't know is
the machine that created dr. Manhattan
angela and laurie meet on the night and
the latter states that she knows that
angela took whatever was injured secret
compartment laurie cannot perform an
autopsy under due to the explosion and
she knows that there is something deeper
going on here she tries to scare Angela
but sis tonight doesn't scare that easy
and she pretty quickly cements that
she's not the pushover that lookingglass
was Laurie ends up sleeping with her
partner making him wear a mask desperate
to reconnect with the life that she once
had even though she is now trapped in a
world where she has been tasked with
taking it down now I'm just gonna go
over the joke that's lace throughout it
and what it means the joke is about a
bricklayer that teaches his daughter how
to build a barbecue and this ends with
her throwing a brick up in the air as
high as she can from here she tells a
joke about three heroes who die and
these are clearly night-owl Ozymandias
and dr. Manhattan these three are judged
by God who decides that they should go
to hell for their misdeeds Silk Spectre
who was given no talent
Marone is asked who she is and she says
I'm the girl who threw the brick in the
air the brick Falls killing God
completely out of the blue which cements
that Lori believes that she could bring
it all crashing down including the live
from the end of the graphic novel and
that she has the power to do it at any
time the hell refers to Jail in which
Nite Owl and Ozzy have been sent to you
and dr. Manhattan's self-imposed exile
on Mars it's a nice joke that is in
keeping with the watchman law and Laurie
leaves the booth at the end wills car
comes crashing down and Laurie ends up
standing there laughing much like how
her father used to this may indeed be
dr. Manhattan reaching out to her or the
craft simply flying away but whatever it
is I think it's building to the return
of the godlike creature as well as
Ozzy's plan to escape and get back to
earth if he is indeed on Mars now this
episode leaves a lot of questions and
I'd obviously love to hear your theories
on it and if you agree with me or not
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoy this video then please give it a
thumbs up and make sure you check out my
breakdown of the season so far which
would be linked at the end I go over
everything that you need to know and the
things you missed so it's definitely
worth checking out if you want to know
more you want to come chat to me after
the video that make sure you follow me
on twitter at definition whitey or head
over to my discord server which would be
linked in the description below those
are the best ways to keep up to date
with all the latest videos on the
channel so hopefully I see you over
there very soon we're also giving away a
free copy of the Marvel phase 3 pot one
boxer blu-ray which contains Civil War
Doctor Strange homecoming Ragnarok and
more and all you have to do to be in
with a chance of winning is like the
video make sure that you subscribe to
the channel and leave your thoughts on
Watchmen in the comments section below
the winners gonna be chosen at random on
the 15th of November and the set will be
shipped out from the end whoever gets
the prize it's the best of luck that
every only takes part
[Music]
this is a channel for people who are
super into superheroes so if that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
[Music]